let's start with uh uh goldie what does
it mean to you
to step into this world as such a rich
mythological character like mrs claus
what does she mean to you well you know
mrs claus didn't used to mean a lot
other than that she was
just mrs claus and she was a nice person
and she was making cookies and
you know we didn't know much about it
what made this special
for me to step into this kind of
character is that what was created for
her
uh which was to create a magical and
this is kurt and chris
so there's a lot of connections and
thinking that went into who
is mrs claus and the idea that she had
magic that she was able to heal that she
was an alchemist
she wills could mix potions together to
basically reduce the
the frost and so forth of the children
and that she really could have a
cauldron to look into to see
what was really going on so she was a
very magical character
and is for me um and one of the more
interesting characters i think i've
played
less exuberant if you will but much more
thoughtful
and also she's kind and loving and i
think a symbol
of of what we would like to have really
a maternal sort of um
connection uh with that and one of the
areas that
that i really love about what she did
and i think i'll take off on like
what you were saying before um is
creating resilience so kids actually can
make mistakes
it's okay um go ahead and get out go out
there into the deep dark forest
okay you can do it i believe in you
that's something that we need to always
talk to our children about and let them
know we believe in them
so anyway i love her
i love that answer i'm going to take
that to heart um
kurt for you uh just tell me everything
about putting together that
darlene love musical number that was
such a
such a treat to enjoy what was it like
playing and singing with her
well i do like hearing that because it's
one of the
probably the one thing when we're doing
these shows that i kind of go oh boy
here we go
listen uh if you're gonna be me playing
santa claus and singing with somebody
um darlene love is a great choice i'm
i'm here to tell you stevie van zandt
created a new song
uh that was great and and chris wanted
to have a new song
uh in the first one chris and i agreed
that there was a
place in the movie we felt there should
be a musical number and it was santa in
the jail and he found this song
that was an elvis song that not many
people knew and i felt comfortable with
that
uh but this is more difficult because
now now it's there's just no connection
to anything
so you're creating a song it always has
to tell story
we put it in the airport we you know was
we knew you know exactly what we were
going to do that whole segment
loved that whole segment of the movie
and uh
and you know so listen it's challenging
um it really is and and uh i just had a
great time with darlene
uh and chris is a big part of pulling
that off and and it's all about stevie's
song so
that was i'm glad you enjoyed it
definitely uh one final quick question
for you
this is christmas chronicles part two
is there a part three a part four or
part five in store
some things that i find aggregated it's
chapter two
it's a book it's a christmas chronicles
it's a chapter
it doesn't mean that you aggravate me no
not not you
i'm playing
um there's no such thing as mr claus
he's saint nicholas
and he's married to mrs claus she has a
name
but we'll never know it and that's for a
significant reason
these things that go into the sort of
bible that set out the parameters i find
to be really important in this
and it's great i mean the answer is we
don't know
because we didn't know there was going
to be a second one
so if we if we go to a third one which
would be
great joy uh to be able to actually
extend this story and make it more
interesting and keep going
it would be amazing so it's up to them
but in the first place if we do a third
one it's not
our choices but in the first one
i realized there was the possibility of
this being
something much bigger than what this
first one was and we set easter eggs in
motion
i'm really glad we did that and we will
follow them as we have to be careful
here we don't want to find ourselves
down the road
violating things that we should have set
up so
we continue to try to do that we
continue to try to through this one
you know we try to set those other
easter eggs
awesome christmas but they're mysteries
um anyway so that that is uh like we
just had the most fun
it was a blast and i mean 33 years for
us we've got one day and last time in
2018
this was uh an awful experience and
it's it's special i mean you know it's
really special